hey guys Giga here with another useless
video so have you been hanging around
YouTube or Twitter you may have seen
these tearless pop-up I don't know you
might have missed them only about two
people have done it at this point it's
pretty new but while we have fast foods
and presidents and youtubers where is
the tier list us weaves really care
about that's right so today I'll be
taking some of the most popular female
characters I can find on my anime list
some relevant seasonal ones and just a
few wild cards for good measure of
course someone like me who has immersed
himself in a study of waifu ology i will
persevere to give the most objective
impartial list that will leave out all
my personal biases you could have seen
that coming
but I mean starting with my literal
goddess would be a bit unfair so you
know if there was one character that
could set the baseline for this list it
would be Ozma if there was a game a girl
of waifu's she would be it hell she is a
game a girl this is kind of as basic an
anime girl as you can get it's like
starting a new game and in the character
creation screen you picked the default
character model and don't edit any of
the base stats her only outstanding
feature is the fact that she doesn't
have any outstanding features detail
Shinobu anime has garnered this
uncomfortable reputation of having these
characters that look suspiciously young
actually be obscenely old and mature of
vampires or demon Lords trapped in a
younger body only those with an
untrained eye will fail to recognize
that Shinobu is clearly 598 years old
and that's why cultured men like ass can
put her 80 and not feel weird about
anything at all cuz we don't this is
normal I swear to god your honor zero -
here's the prime example of a girl who
has topped the charts from the
aesthetics quality while forgetting to
put any of the stats back into the
character if we were going by design
alone she would have easily been best
girl of 2018 she's got the unique look
the unique quirks I'm pretty sure she's
the only waifu that can claim to be a
spaceship but it says a lot about how
strong these traits are wishing can go
from crazy murderous rampage to
non-existent character and still be best
curling your shows that we haven't
forgotten be tear a car made from a car
mega kill more like edgy enough to make
me a calm and go kill myself
Ichigo now Ichigo gets a lot of hate for
having the audacity to complete
but I think she has some positives going
for her I mean just imagine waking up to
this face next to you every morning and
personally I can't think of a better way
to start my day because then I already
know the day couldn't get any worse
black hole Chan this is what happens
when you take any kind of monumental
scientific achievement and give it to
the anomie community to completely ruin
here we have a girl who has the massive
6.5 billion suns concentrated into a
point so dense it has a gravitational
pull that can physically distort
space-time so you can see what's so
special about black hole challenge she's
very much into four she loves war this
is war personally I think we found a new
fetish of a girl that'll suck so hard
even after you nuts
she'll just keep sucking until every
atom that makes you up gets ripped apart
at a subatomic level why tear Evangelion
girls you've got to pay respect to the
classics and Oscar is a true OG that
holds a close place in my teenage heart
she pioneered cinder days and there are
a few even today that can hold a candle
to her they say you'd never forget your
first but as you grow older you move on
and become wiser some say you realize
you're an adult when you start taking
responsibility for your own actions
however the true sign of adulthood is
when you live there's an ask a kind of
kids only to grow up and realize that
you've become a mossad oh man ray though
still remains the AVA girl equivalent of
stepping in a wet pile of wood socks on
ram now i know i've memed up ram a lot
but even i can see how she got the
popularity that she did I mean she's a
sweetheart she sticks with you and
she'll lift you up during your darkest
times so right here I think she should
get a bit of the recognition that she
deserves
well Hinata I got to be honest I'm not
the biggest fan of this character
archetype the shy lovestruck girl that
only comes out there she'll to the
person they like I think the technical
term is dander eh but I much prefer the
term doormat however I have to give a
credit because she is one of the only
short bluehead anime girl that has ever
ended up with the guy they liked because
she persevered and was true to her
feelings and protected her love in the
hardest of times and most importantly
she grew Hera proving that all the
doormats can dream of one day growing up
to become carpet Oh Chico from my hero
academia Oh Chico is a good hard-working
girl all she wants to do is to make
money so she can take care of her
parents how straightforward is that she
is the definition of a pure cinnamon
roll and that's why I'm gonna put her in
the Panera bread's here megameter de
couro she's like Oh Chico but just not
as refined a pastry and what's a less
elegant cinnamon roll that's right
a sausage roll Greg's tier Hina and Rui
winter seasons domestic girlfriend
really put to test the eternal battle
and why food trash emoto's vs. oh nice
Emma's little sis vs big sis onii-chan
vs ara ara
whatever your preference don't forget
the die-hard rule to live by when
talking about siblings in anime if she's
not blood-related she's free to be dated
see Tia Jabbar me you Mako I once said
don't stick your dick in crazy and
Jabbar me is [ __ ] crazy any sane
person can see that so any guy could
actually try something with her would
obviously only be able to think with
their dicks fortunately my dick has an
IQ of 200
senko son Sanka son takes up the role of
seasonal why for you that you end up
seeing everywhere because of their
reaction faces you got the power face
she got the blood face and you've got
the holy grail of all anime reaction
faces the I got the smug face this makes
them a prime target family profile
pictures because they can make people
think that they embody the spirit of a
cute anime girl not realizing that it
doesn't actually mask over their
degeneracy and anything they say online
will now never be taken seriously
however these girls are only really a
strong pick until the season ends at
which point they then get immediately
disposed of
dear and I'm next week
[Music]
[Applause]
this is what a true waifu goddess looks
like and with that evolution her stats
have totally put her up into st r sagar
e okay let me be real for a second i owe
a lot to Sakurai and I know I said I
would stay unbiased but in the end era
manga sensei was one of my first big
memes that got me quite popular and
Sagar II was right in the middle of that
so FBI memes aside on a personal level
there's only one place I could really
put her how her he Suzumiya imagine
being so desperate for friends that the
only reason anyone hangs out you is to
prevent the [ __ ] apocalypse chika
this is the closest thing in anime you'd
find to a drug addiction if you're
having a bad day you just inject this
[ __ ] right into your veins and for a
moment it can make you forget about the
drudging monotony that is your life
despite being a seasonal go I think
she's left a strong enough impression to
be beat here Mari from me to darkest a
key
rin tohsaka rin will always be one of
the greats because to me rain involves
the highest quality at tsundere can be
while still being a pure tsundere some
of these top tier girls have sin traits
and sin moments that are blended with
other things but Rin isn't out-and-out
tsundere that manages to differentiate
herself from the rest she is what
happens when every tinder date rate is
refined to the highest degree she has
the twin tails she has the thigh-highs
she has the blush I'd literally die in
reincarnate into another world to
protect and the mix between sin and dead
a so perfectly balanced
she alone could have been the most
effective weapon against thanasis now
sto calorie spoilers for your line April
you know how an anime characters will
stereotypically wait for like two
seasons before holding hand and like
five years to confess well Carrie here
is so extra in our patience to let her
true feelings known that by the time she
decided to confess she was [ __ ] dead
she gets a D for deceased departed done
for dominatrix Speedwagon every so often
you come across someone that has it all
the looks the charm the loyalty
Speedwagon embodies everything a waifu
should be and more but i know what
you're thinking how can this 200-pound
hunk of pure man meat count as a waifu
and that's so short-sighted because you
fail to see that wife wisdom is in the
heart here's a bro that will give you
the devotion you deserve more than any
other waifu kirk he will never leave you
he isn't gay he simply ran out of women
that were worthy
like Speedwagon what kind of man doesn't
easily an sto and that was pretty much
everyone had time for right now if you
disagree with anything I said yeah it's
pretty it's probably because you're
wrong uh be sure to tune in next week
when you can see my scheduled apology
video hey guys hope you enjoyed that
video thank you very much this month to
Mike
elfin sisters one zero zero eight six
Ella for Robert on vork battle now Ken
and everyone else on my patreon for
helping just for me for this month and
making this video possible just to
reminder that I will be guessing at
moment con at the end of this month so
if any of you are in Atlanta and are
going on the last weekend of May then I
look forward to see you there by the way
is actually the weekend before my
birthday see if you see me hanging
around the bar just feel free to get me
a drink so funny thing I actually
recorded this video last week and I
couldn't get it finished in time before
I started traveling so I'm actually a
moment con right now so if you see me
around the corner you at MoMA con feel
free to come say hi and you can also
check my twitter at giga AZ for any
updates on any schedules and signings
and panels I'm doing anyway that's it
for me I've been gig art and I'll see
you all next time